if you want to control your own destiny
you work for yourself everybody should
at least try at least taste it and see
if it's for them is in everyone but not
everyone has a discipline for but anyone
could be an entrepreneur rise and shine
it's expresso time what's up believe
nation it's Evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
an amazing gift inside you that I want
to see exploded onto the world so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
work for yourself over to you Kevin
O'Leary I was working once in an
ice-cream parlor when I was about 15
years old my first real job and on the
second day I was asked to scrape the gum
off between the Mexican tiles on the
floor and I said to the woman who owned
the stores called my boobs ice cream
parlor you didn't hire me to scrape gum
you hired me to scoop ice cream and this
this girl was shoe store across the way
that's looking at me I don't want to see
her you scraping the gum and she said
what you're talking about I own this
store I'll do anything I want with you
get down on your knees and script that
gum when I said I'm not doing it she
said you're fired last job I ever had I
owe that woman everything I don't like
to work for people many of you in here I
hope and inherit that there's nothing
wrong with it if you want to control
your own destiny you work for yourself
that's how it works I'm trying to
inspire those of you are on the tipping
point take the chance you're young go
for it
there's nothing better than being able
to wake up in the morning 10 years or 20
years so now and
do what ever you like it's about freedom
that's what matters
I'm not saying being an employee's bad
but believe me being an entrepreneur is
better I'm a little biased so I don't
know that everybody needs to be an
entrepreneur but I do think everybody
should at least try at least taste it to
see if it's for them first off the
reason to get a job is to learn to learn
the ropes so yes make a little bit of
money but the reason to fundamentally
get a job is to learn if you are not
learning in your job you are not going
to be happy no matter how much money
you're making some people make tons of
money but are never happy because they
are not learning they are not growing
they're not progressing that has to be
the fundamental base and that could
ultimately lead to you certain young
business but if you are not being
treated with respect if you were being
yelled at by your boss who says get on
your floors and scrape that gum and
that's not what you want to be learning
how to do then the answer is leave the
job but it may be go to a different job
where you're going to learn from
somebody and really be mentored it
doesn't have to be jump and do your
business I just want to provide some
alternatives I want you to make the
right decision for you that being said I
think everybody should try
entrepreneurship everybody should try to
have a YouTube channel everybody should
try to write a book I think you need to
try more things I think everybody has
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and you don't even know what it is
because you locked yourself in way too
early on the career path and you haven't
tried anything else it's like if you're
at home and your mom gives you a bowl of
spaghetti and then all you want to do
for the rest of your life is eat
spaghetti and you say spaghetti is your
favorite food of all time but you
haven't tried burritos and you haven't
tried sushi and you haven't tried dim
sum you just never tried it and so
you're gonna eat spaghetti never knowing
what else there is in the world
available to you you have Michael Jordan
level talent at something but you're not
doing it because you didn't explore
enough things and so I think everybody
should try athletics everybody should
try to write a book YouTube channel all
of it you should try it try it
say yes and just taste it just to see
and the result doesn't have to be you
are amazing you might get in front of a
camera make your first video and
absolutely suck well the thing is did
you enjoy it do you want to go back
you want to say yes you want to try it
again just like when you go on a date
your first date you don't have to marry
that person you just want to go back for
a second date then I like them enough to
go back on a second date and the more
you keep going back eventually you get
married and so I think people just don't
say yes enough I think people just don't
try enough things I think you need to
explore you need to break out of your
cocoon you need to stop doing the things
that you just do in your family because
that's the way it's always been done or
your city or your community your culture
you need to break free that's why people
get so many ideas when they go travel
they go traveling they get some we need
to see how different cultures are doing
things they get a little bit of a taste
of something else that's different and
unique and we get addicted to it people
want to travel traveling at some point
gets boring ultimately you want to do
you're interested in trouble because
it's stimulating you're learning
something new but if you spent your all
day traveling all the time traveling you
get bored of it because you want people
want to create you want to make you want
to do you want to have meaning and so
finding that thing that you could be the
Michael Jordan of in your business in
your industry that's the game and so I
think you should try to be an
entrepreneur I think everybody should
try and my early days of
entrepreneurship wasn't this my early
days of entrepreneurship was selling my
crayon paintings and selling baseball
cards in lemonade stains and a whole
bunch of little things that sure I had a
lot of failures and sure I made a little
bit of money selling baseball cards and
that kind of stuff and ultimately led me
to where I am now but if I didn't get
that taste I don't know that I would be
an entrepreneur right now I probably be
a banker which I said I wanted to be in
my high school yearbook and hating my
life and hating my job and hating what
I'm doing like most of my high school
friends do not find satisfaction in the
work that they are doing because they
locked themselves too early in on a path
that maybe they decided for themselves
maybe their parents decided for them but
they're down this path now and they
can't wait to get off but they can't
they feel they can't they feel they
can't because now they've locked
themselves in they have a house they
have a mortgage they have a car they
have a family and it's too risky for
them to jump off that's a topic for a
different video but if you are in a job
that you do not like ultimately remember
the point of a job is to learn
are you learning at this job are you
gaining contacts are you gaining
knowledge
you getting an understanding of what you
can do better if not first blame
yourself is there anything you can do
more can you talk to your boss and
volunteer to do bigger projects even if
you're not getting paid volunteer to
learn and if you're not getting that
opportunity they're treating you like
crap
great leave and the option maybe you go
get another job and the option could be
the start of business and the option
could be a thousand different variations
and at the beginning just taste
everything just try open your mouth
and bring in the world try so you don't
end up like most people driving to a job
that you hate every single morning
knowing that there's way more potential
inside you and taking fewer and fewer
and fewer yeses and changes and
opportunities because you've locked
yourself in on the path that you feel
that you cannot get off of say yes you
try now I've got a really special bonus
clip that I think you're going to enjoy
but before that question of the day I
want to know what is one thing that you
want to try it could be a business idea
it could be a food it could be a sport
it could be salsa dancing what is just
one thing what's the first thing that
comes to mind you watch this video I'm
speaking these words to you right now
what's the first thing that comes to
mind I could be cool finish this
sentence
it would be cool to try right what is
that word write it down I want to see in
the comments below and then just find
the smallest possible way to get started
often release that anxiety that fear
those nerves and just find some small
way to do it if you train yourself to do
that I guarantee you I guarantee you or
guarantee your life will begin to change
for the positive
leave me comments below thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much loved
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
let's pray so give me go
I think our viewership is in everyone
but not everyone has a disciplined for
but anyone could be an entrepreneur but
not everyone wants to be an octave in
the way some people radler dependent on
other people because they feel like they
have to work as hard but being an
entrepreneur means working hard
it means embracing struggle it means
being a leader then we're never sending
somebody to do something that you
wouldn't do yourself a real boss would
never send somebody to do something way
to do themself a boss that tells
somebody to do something I think we do
is not a bosses account and I got that
both principals came to me from the
people I knew in his feet right so
somebody taught me like you'll kill that
[ __ ] for labor - then you can kill
yourself
I'm know all about I'm saying I think we
control our own destiny and so whether
David makes it or not has nothing to do
with sort of the size of the might of
Goliath and if you're thinking like that
you'll probably always be able to find a
reason and frankly an excuse in some
lame answer as to why you can't win
because the markets aren't good I was in
the middle of this and you know through
2000 in the first crash and people are
going it's mark it's terrible mark it's
terrible like I'm selling stretchy
t-shirts not nothing to do with the
financial crisis it's like sports are
gonna be played and kids will wear it or
they won't and you know I think anybody
can you can look and find but I
challenge all of us to say stop finding
reasons to find and make excuses that
you know we affectionately underarmor
call loser talk
and I don't know you you've got to just
will it and and focus on on making it
happen and as Bruce Lee said if you
always put limits on everything you do
physical or anything else it will spread
into your work and into your life there
are no limits there are only plateaus
and you must not stay there you must go
beyond them
even in the statement you can see him
making the choice about what to believe
by saying that there are no limits by
taking something that other people
perceive as a limit is something that's
stopping him and saying that's not it's
a plateau it's something that I can push
through and you see what he holds
himself accountable to it's not okay to
stay at a plateau it's okay to have one
everybody has them they happen it's a
natural part of the course of getting
better but it is not okay to stay there
and that is a choice that's not
something anyone can hand you it's
something you have to believe to the
core of your soul that it is not okay to
stay in a plateau and it's that that's
gonna push you through it's that that's
gonna make you get up and keep going but
first you have to recognize that life is
cause-and-effect you have to recognize
that that choice is a knock-on effect
you have to recognize that him merely
saying those words out loud have a cause
and effect
they changed the course of his life the
expectations that other people have of
him expectations that he has of himself
and because he understands that he can
control the outside world by first
controlling what's inside by changing
his belief system to match what he wants
to accomplish he's then able to
accomplish what he did in his life have
nothing to do with luck it had
everything to do with the demands that
he made on himself it had to do with
winning he got in a motorcycle accident
people told him he would never walk
again not only did he walk again all of
the major accomplishments that we think
about it being that man they all came
after they came after he was told he was
never gonna walk came after he was told
that he was never going to be able to do
martial arts but he did it he did the
grueling work of getting better he
understood cause and effect he
understood that if he chose to believe
that he could never do it that he'd
never be able to do it but that if he
chose to believe that by working out he
could get stronger and get better and
get back to it
and that's what he did so now ask
yourself is your life dictated by luck
or cause and effect are you in control
or is it somebody else is someone else
in control or is it you and if it's you
go build the life that you want because
there's nothing stopping you you have
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details